[Music]
so for some of the people I interviewed
and squeezed when they were going
through economic hardship they would
they get sick physically they'd be
psychologically troubled they'd have to
go on anti-anxiety medication and
sometimes they would have never they
wouldn't even have health care so that
would be an added expense some of the
subjects might experience something
called decision fatigue where they'd be
unable to make decisions or choices in
their lives basic choices because
they've been so overwhelmed by the
feeling of economic uncertainty they
were thinking constantly how do I
survive rather than how do I lead a
better life or how do I get my kid on
the best course and that that's a common
place I'm sort of just that overwhelmed
aspect when you didn't have when you
don't have resources that's all you're
thinking about one of the challenges for
people seeking employment and the gig
economy is that they're disposable right
they can always be replaced by somebody
else they may not have relationships
with another human being at uber or at
lyft whatever that supposedly it's this
idea of independence but it's often like
in fact this kind of free-floating
quality where they're not they're not
connected to clearly connected to a boss
or colleagues and I think that can be
really dangerous because then these
people's experience is not humanized to
the people who are hiring them they're
just cogs and wheels and we should
really start thinking about that because
I think it can be really debilitating I
talked about teachers who drive uber in
a chapter and I think for many of them
they were recruited by the company they
had a motto four or five years ago
uber teachers driving our future so
teachers and nurses were attractive to
ober simply as middle-class icons but
they weren't attractive enough to you
know the people in their community who
were they were teaching or the
politicians in their community to give
them a wage so they wouldn't have to
drive uber on the side so to me that's
one of the dangers of the gig economy to
you that that the formerly middle class
can be
use just as a symbol and you know a kind
of respectability that they can be
offering these companies wow they're
kind of rippling through these
one-sample professions for solid people
that they can exploit many of the people
I wrote about are not in organizations
or even in corporations their contingent
which means that they work part-time on
contracts they work gigs which is this
is now a huge amount of the population
and/or they work too few hours to be
counted as employees right so you know
I'm not sure it's becomes an
organizational thing most of the time
but if it in terms of what we're doing
an economic hardship reporting project
we're trying to pay journalists who've
fallen on hard times a dollar word plus
expenses and that's just like one small
way to keep them afloat you know we have
people writing for us who we're living
without heat on food stamps on medet you
know at a government medic medical care
you know they were really struggling and
this is one one app thing that I've
noticed has been interesting lately
I call them sort of white-collar on
labor it was like white-collar unions
almost for you know journalists for
other employees that in the past were
not necessarily unionized freelance
journalists and what we're doing is part
of that but there's all sorts of other
things cropping up there are collectives
for caregivers that I've written about
so they're sort of working together
they're owning the apps where they rent
out there where they try to get
customers and for house cleaning or
nannying and so I think what kind of
organizations do organizations can try
to empower their poor workers by giving
them resources both economic and from
the companies themselves for instance
like an app that they themselves would
own a part of rather than just simply
the company owning the app and the
worker just his teeny piece of the you
know teeny TaskRabbit they would instead
own the own that be a part of the app
/ tips is another way I think we can
start thinking about that especially you
know web-based cooperatives that's
becoming really important given the
concentration of wealth or you have a
teeny number of people owning these
companies and just hundreds of thousands
of people working for them driving uber
cleaning houses etc we can start talking
about people owning a share of the
digital economy and the gig work that
they're doing
[Music]